what does a morning look like for you at
the moment if you've got a routine of
some kind yes I run every single morning
so that's time you up when are you
waking up I'm up about 5 5 30. so every
morning it starts with the run and
that's because that's the one thing I
hate to do more than anything in the
world
so that's like my cup of coffee
and I'm all about armoring yourself
so the second you leave your house
and you second you open your phone the
second you do any of that you are now
letting in poison in cancer
so I make sure a lot of things you can't
avoid
so as I get up I start to armor plate my
mind and body like a person's going to
war you put your body armor on that's
what I'm doing on that run
I'm waking up and I'm giving myself all
this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm gonna get hit in the mouth
there's a there's an art to getting hit
in the [ __ ] mouth
and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give yourself belief you have to
give yourself confidence so that it
starts with that run
so after the run
I come home I eat something small how
long's the Run typically at the moment
nowhere Under 12 miles
so 12 miles is the minimum I'm already
getting that done in how long it depends
right now I'm running a heart rate so
I'm doing it like 8 15s 8 30s because
I'm retraining right now because it's
not zone two for you zone two yeah
because of the leg surgery I had so I'm
going back starting from scratch so
anywhere from about an hour 30 to two
hours I run every day
so so you're fasted on the morning oops
straight out straight out 90 minutes to
two hours of running back eat and I'm in
the gym
so and then after that
um to whatever's on the plan for the day
that's how that works every day are you
still doing your stretching because
you've got two hours of every night two
hours of meditation 90 minutes to two
hours of running how long is the gym
session depends 45 to an hour and a half
okay
stretching meditation run eat mm-hmm Jim
[Music]
what is that my mission Jennifer
oh yeah yeah forget about that you cycle
as well yeah how long are you cycling it
just depends I do stationary bike right
now a lot what are you using is it like
a what bike or something similar yeah
something similar so I put my bike on a
uh like trainer and I cycle yep at least
three or four days a week I'll do that
so
that's your day there's no there's there
is no room for anything else
yeah there is a lot of room so there's
24 hours and I use it all pretty pretty
well how's your sleep what's your sleep
like it's really good okay eight hours
something like that seven eight hours
yeah but you need to with this sort of
volume seven eight hours and you're
still doing your stretching stuff every
night
so you've got a four hour block
basically of stretching and meditation
you combine the two right yeah that's
all in one block cool
yep that's one hell of a day it is and
it's been like that for
seven years but going back to what you
said before about needing to cap success
you wouldn't be able to fit well even
one tenth of that in exactly if you were
chasing down exactly yep that's exactly
it so if all that's [ __ ] up that's why
I got a cap success because I can't put
that in do and and that's my growth
factor
so you know that's that's my human
growth factor you said before about
um how you build up self-esteem and
confidence and stuff and there's this
quote from one of my friends Alex homozy
that says you don't become Confident by
shouting affirmations in the mirror but
by having a stack of undeniable proof
that you are who you say you are outwork
yourself doubt yes
that's that's nailed nailed completely
nailed yes because a lot of people will
in some of these motivational people out
here is the funniest thing in the world
to me they'll go and say when you wake
up in the morning pound your chest you
know [ __ ] look at yourself in the
mirror and do all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
I hope it works
what works for me is that everyday
resume the things I know of accomplished
the things I know I've done real hard
work the real calluses on my mind the
real calluses on my hands that's that's
it the you don't need to pound your
chest in the mirror to [ __ ] anymore if
you have that it seems like especially
with confidence right or self-esteem
there's a relationship between
confidence and competence so what you're
looking to do is try and have what you
believe that you can do be ahead of what
you can do right you're not looking for
it to be delusional you don't want it to
to be able to believe that you can do
something like fly right but you need to
have a relationship between the two but
what people are asking for is for their
confidence to be so far ahead of their
competence that or without having even
been competent to anything in the
beginning and that's just delusion
that's fantasy right well I believe that
you have to build belief
belief is like there's an after-school
special belief where the mom says
believe in yourself and that's all great
but there's also a built belief
and the built belief is one where you
are constantly like for me I came from a
bad place How I build belief is through
the the daunting tasks
I put myself through so that's proof
positive that I can
so it correlates and that's how this
piece of [ __ ] kid I once thought I was
don't believe by saying hmm
I was in three hell weeks I went to
Ranger school I tried out for Delta
selection undeniable stack of proof that
is proof [ __ ] so whenever you
think whenever you think you can't
confidence comes from the thing that you
built
you must build belief you must build
confidence it can be like hey
um I'm Gonna Knock that [ __ ] out
you gotta look over here and say
I can knock that [ __ ] out
is belief and it's built on what you put
in to yourself another friend sent me a
message this morning knowing that we had
this this big thing that we've been
working toward for a long time today he
said uh Nietzsche said I know of no
better life purpose than to perish in
attempting the great and impossible the
fact that something seems impossible
shouldn't be a reason to not pursue it
that's exactly what makes it worth
pursuing where would the courage and
greatness be if success was certain and
there was no risk the only true failure
is shrinking away from life's challenges
you know that one also two for two no
that one also man yeah it's that um
it's not dealing with laziness and
self-doubt thing I think uh
and I do wonder how many people use the
look in the mirror pound the chest stare
into your eyes say your affirmations
don't get the results and then lose
confidence
well that's part of it a lot of it is
limited Horizons
limited Horizons are like I use me as an
example always
I came from
a small town in Indiana
where there was a handful of black
families
and
a lot of people in that town when you
come from a town of 8 000 people
it's like we had a local plant
Great Dane and like you know what I
wanna
work at Great Dane and get a house next
to my mom
that's what you know
so many of us
come from these small places in our mind
that we're not willing to think outside
of only what we've seen
our mind works in such a small
compartment
and one thing I was able to do was to
dream
many people but don't make dreams your
[ __ ] master
but I was able to dream outside those
[ __ ] Four Walls of that small town
and until you're able to really put
yourself into that dream but don't make
dreams your master that's where you
truly become what you're destined to
become what you mean don't make dreams
your master a lot of people sit back and
they dream about being
a sports figure or dream about being a
seal or dream about being an astronaut
and all it is is a [ __ ] dream
they don't put the work behind the dream
that dream has become their [ __ ]
master
when you become the master of your
[ __ ] dream is when you say I want to
go be a Navy SEAL and you say okay I'm
gonna lose 106 pounds in less than three
[ __ ] months
the dream was the one thing I thought
about and the dream was now gone now
what comes in the dream goes away and
the [ __ ] laundry list the [ __ ]
details and tasks come up gotta do this
God do this God do this God do this
that's when you become the master of
your dream
so a lot of people out there dreaming
Ryan holiday says talking about the
thing and doing the thing Vie for the
same resources allocate yours
appropriately that's it
that's it
that's the way it works as well that's
the way that the brain works you can
actually get these kicks of dopamine by
telling your friends about I'm going to
be a Navy SEAL I'm going to start my
training next week it's going to be
great I'm going to feel like this feels
good it feels good to talk about that
[ __ ] man it actually makes you feel good
makes you feel proud all that [ __ ] but
guess what happens that alarm clock goes
off at 4 a.m to train
um
I want to be a seal today but I don't
want to be whatever today I'll start
tomorrow and that's the usual pattern of
people's lives
that's why
I talk about clearing out the mind
until you really want to do something
you're always going to be a talker you
always get run your [ __ ] mouth this
episode is brought to you by element
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything that you need and
nothing that you don't I've replaced my
morning coffee with element every day
for over three years now and I've never
looked back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Goggins then press here for the full
episode in all of its glory and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]